for the first 170 years from 1600 right
up to 1770. uh the English State gathers
uh harvests great sums of money from the
East India Company apart from the
employment that it's providing apart
from the profits that it's generating uh
it's also generating huge sums in income
tax and in customs particularly customs
and I think nearly half the nation's
Customs comes from East India Company
Imports uh so no one's asking too many
questions about where this stuff is
coming from but in 1770 after winning
the battles of placid and Buxton having
then done what companies will do which
is effectively asset strip and loot
um Bengal so this place which had the
one million Weavers which is the if you
like the the goose laying the golden
eggs they they kill the goose they they
they they strip the the goose bear uh
they pluck the goose so viciously that
in 1770 when there's a famine there are
no reserves anywhere now you know famine
is something that's happened come to
India many times in its history and and
Anyone who reads travel accounts of
people traveling in there will have come
across accounts of terrible famines it's
not something that the East India
Company or the British invent but what's
new is that the company has no grain
Reserves Indian Indian rulers know that
in in years of plenty they must put
aside grain reserves and they also know
that that during a family members
provide employment so a lot of the most
beautiful buildings in India are built
by Indian rulers
um at a ridiculous scale to provide
employment during families so the most
obviously the uh the great imambara and
Lucknow which is one of the great
buildings of of North India off the
tourist Trail but uh spectacular and
highly recommended to anyone who wants
to see fine 18th century Indian
architecture that is built by the nawab
of luck now at this period as time and
relief measures and starving people are
given a rupee a day if they start moving
bricks and stone around and helping
build this enormous building now these
City companies does nothing of this and
as a result
um the numbers have recently sort of
been come down they've been very
detailed Regional studies of how many
people died in Islamic but it's still a
million people it's a million dead
bengalis
and I mean sometimes the numbers are
giving us three or even five million and
these now seem to be uh unlikely but you
know vast and horrific uh Channel heaps
and bodies bodies being washed down the
Ganges dogs picking up corpses
and this is really horrifying it's death
on such a massive scale and so
unprecedented that for the first time we
get whistleblowers uh you get people
writing accounts and sending it back
anonymously to magazines because you
know there are no award-winning
journalists there are no Capital Puris
flying in to report from the front line
or or uh ragiomas or their equivalents
um
but finally you get reports turning up
in The Spectator of the gentleman's
magazine uh of anonymous correspondence
describing the utter horror of corpses
flies vultures dogs picking at the
things I mean and and even today these
accounts you know we're used to seeing
starvation on on television and so on
but even today uh these accounts are
incredibly upsetting and lurid
so
um then what's the company's response
they are worried about their profits
because it's a company they now need the
land revenues generated by Indians to
buy their investment to buy the the
cotton they need to buy so they send out
their armies to The Villages
and in addition to the corpses which are
lying on the ground through starvation
there are now gibbits put up in every
village and anyone who doesn't pay their
taxes even if they're starving is Hun
and when the news arrives at the annual
general meeting that the East India
company has managed to gather its taxes
in full despite one million casualties
from admin the shareholders are so
pleased they vote themselves an
increased dividend from 10
to 12 and a half percent
so this is knowingly celebrating
successful fleecing of Indians I mean
it's in a sense it's the clearest moment
when you see the the you know what this
ultimately boils down to which is piles
and corpses uh and then very rich people
in London getting their dividends in
their in their Banks
so it continues the same for another
year by 1772 they have stripped the
bones clean there is nothing left to to
harvest they can't Harvest any more
Revenue because there is no more Revenue
and the news of that arrives in London
there is horror 30 Banks collapse across
Europe the United company goes to the
newly founded Bank of England but they
haven't got enough money to bail it out
yet it is literally too big to fail it
employs too many people too much of the
country's revenue for the government
allow it to allow it to to collapse what
do they do they basically buy a 50 share
of it they lend it four million pounds
and that bails out the extended company
but there is a price to pay and that is
the regulatory act which means that the
government now overlooks the the
extended companies so from this point it
becomes what I suppose today we call a
private public-private partnership and
this only the government uh interest in
the company then only increases until
finally in 1858 following the great
Uprising which the Indians call the
first war of independence but which the
uh British uh called the Indie Mutiny
still
uh when another million people die this
time from in action against the East
India Company Parliament finally says
enough and they effectively nationalized
the company in 1858. and it becomes an
entirely government-run operation but
for the 250 years before that
it isn't the government operation it is
a private Enterprise it is it is like
Facebook or Google or uh or Amazon
Amazon I suppose being the closest uh
parallel day
and and you say the story of the East
India company has never been more
current are there are there companies
today or in recent times who are just so
powerful who might be worth more than
the GBP of some countries who can
exercise their corporate power in a way
that's similar to the the East India
Company who can topple governments for
example or even have senior roles in in
government
do you can you see that can can you see
the ghosts of the East India Company in
in corporates today well of course I
mean you know you don't have to be a
kind of you know a a leftist activist to
point to concrete moments in the last in
the history of the last 60 years when
you've had exactly that I mean the most
famous I suppose
um maybe not as famous as it should be
but uh in in 1950s Iran
um there's a democratic election and
mossadec is elected and one of the first
things he says he's going to do is
nationalize the Anglo Persian
now when this is announced the CIA
anemics get to work and this is not
fiction this is not a movie they get to
work and they organize a coup and the
sharp Iran takes over and he doesn't
at least uh anglo-person oil similar
thing happened two years later in
Guatemala when another socialist
government comes to uh comes to power
and United Fruit who owned 40 of their
own cultural land of Guatemala
um get the CIA to perform another coup
and topple the government wants to
nationalize their interests and that who
produces the phrase Banana Republic
Bruce have been making their banana
Empire uh in Guatemala then in 1977 ITT
get the CIA to topple salvadorendi and
you get one of the most hideous
dictatorships in in Latin American
history all those disappeared and the
women looking for their children all
that stuff happens after ITT persuade
the CIA to intervene now in our own time
we don't know still know the full story
but the strong suspicions that America
cannot interest particularly Exxon had a
lot to do with the invasion of San Jose
Iraq which of course we know had nothing
to do with 9 11. 911 was was uh was
Al-Qaeda full of Saudis uh it wasn't
Saudi Arabia that gets invaded and it
was Saddam Hussein's Iraq who wasn't the
enemy of al-Qaeda how did that happen at
least in part it was the low-being of
Exxon uh and Exxon if it were a country
today would be the 14th richest country
in the world so this is not sort of you
know uh Netflix fantasy that we watch in
the evening to entertain us after our
work this is what corporations can do
and corporations being very rich have
resources the East India Company created
this system
the first time the company is found
influencing a body legislature
is in 1690 only 90 years into its
history and already it's found offering
share options to MPS who vote to
increase its Monopoly you mentioned the
fact that by the 18th century about 40
of MPS have East India company shares
they obviously don't want to clip the
wins too badly
um but you also get by the end of the
18th century something even more noxious
which is returned nabobs who shipped
home fortunes of 100 200 300 000 pounds
from India
um buy rotten boroughs and actually
create a parliamentary faction within
parliament of their own which can which
can you know change change the votes
because there are 20 30 40 MPS who are
of the East India Company interest so
through lobbying through bribery
um and through just quiet influence the
East India Company creates a world for
the first time where a corporate
interest can turn its interest into the
policy of a government and altering
making the interest of the shareholders
the interest that seemed to be the
interest of the state
and that's of course A system that
exists today you know Exxon has you know
it's not a it's not a secret it acts on
employees Senators it gives them
salaries to lobby for it uh and other
other businesses like Facebook Amazon
and Google have the same to protect them
from taxes uh so I mean there are huge
differences obviously Amazon does not
contain and does not have fighter jets
or nuclear submarines which will be the
equivalent of The Cutting Edge East
Indica armies of the 18th century but in
in some ways you could argue that you
know these corporations today are richer
sorry are not richer ah well they are
richer but they're also more powerful
because of surveillance capitalism you
know anyone that's got their phone on
listening to us this evening May well
get East India Company tea adverts in
their social media feed tomorrow morning
um yeah you know the the way that our
conversations can be spied on the way
we've all had these things where
um
you know we've mentioned a particular
brand in conversation and Bingo's there
tomorrow in your Instagram feed or your
Facebook or Twitter is exactly the
corporation that you mentioned in
conversation uh so this is going on and
this is a different sort of power uh but
it's no certainly no lesser power
foreign